y volvemos a hablar de economía en esta
nueva hora de directo américa de france
24 y por supuesto nos acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela hablamos
de rusia y la gente que se puede ver
perjudicada con esta nueva sanción
porque al país ya no van a llegar más
artículos de lujo procedentes de la
unión europea así es raúl pues el bloque
de los 27 países aprobó un nuevo
conjunto de sanciones para castigar a
moscú por su invasión en ucrania estas
incluyen prohibiciones de inversiones en
el sector energético ruso pero también
las empresas de este grupo de países ya
no van a poder llevar a rusia artículos
de lujo que cuesten más de 300 euros
incluidas joyas tampoco vehículos que
cuesten más de 50 mil euros como parte
de un castigo directamente dirigido a
los magnates se prohibirán asimismo las
importaciones de productos siderúrgicos
desde este país también las
transacciones con algunas empresas
estatales de la industria militar y se
congelan los activos de más líderes
empresariales
danny y también reino unido amplió su
castigo esta es una manera también de
ponerse al día con las medidas
restrictivas de la unión europea que
ahora se aplican a 862 personas y 53
entidades pues el reino unido- que no se
queda atrás y que ya no hace parte de
este bloque dijo que ha impuesto más de
1000 sanciones la nueva ronda a punta de
élites con un patrimonio conjunto de más
de 130 mil millones de dólares y cómo
afecta también esta guerra a la
industria automotriz pues ellos ya
vienen de recuperarse más o menos de la
pandemia del coronavirus y ahora es la
guerra la que está golpeando la
industria automotriz específicamente en
alemania en donde algunos fabricantes de
automóviles como volkswagen han tenido
que detener temporalmente su producción
o parte de ella y es que esta firma
trabaja con más de una docena de
proveedores ucranianos que producen
principalmente los sistemas de cableado
de los vehículos que proporcionan
electricidad a componentes como las
luces traseras pero no es la única
empresa audi y bmw w también han tenido
que detener temporalmente la producción
en varias de sus fábricas
distinguirse y así la crisis continúa
desarrollándose como se ve en este
momento tendrá que haber reubicación es
de estos proveedores a otras regiones
esto significa que se debe esperar
escasez de estas piezas faltantes
durante meses
ante todo este contexto mundial que
estamos viviendo danny argentina
suspendió la exportación de harina y
aceite de soya porque lo hace en medio
de un repunte de los precios de todas
las materias primas en especial de los
alimentos
y pues también en medio de la guerra
entre rusia y ucrania que fue la que
ocasionó ese aumento de precios esta
medida en argentina que regirá hasta
nuevo aviso consiste en el cierre de
registros de operaciones que lo que en
la práctica básicamente significa que
bloquea las ventas externas varios
agricultores protestaron porque ellos
consideran que esta suspensión es apenas
un preámbulo de lo que será un aumento
del impuesto a las ventas al exterior
que hoy es del 31 por ciento y subirían
justamente porque no nos dejan producir
es uno de los argentinas es uno de los
pocos países del mundo que tiene
retenciones que se les cobra por
producir que se les cobra por exportar
eso no existe ningún partido en ningún
país del mundo estamos en un país
completamente imprevisible eso hace que
que empresarios del mundo demás o sea
nadie quiere invertir en nuestro país
por esa falta de previsibilidad y osea
ver eso que no se puede seguir así con
estas medidas es una irresponsabilidad y
una falta de compromiso total y ahora
ciudadanía ante todo esto cómo están los
mercados mundiales todos pendientes por
supuesto de ucrania pero en asia la
bolsa de hong kong que esta vez cae por
cuenta de los nuevos confinamientos en
china en europa los mercados se tiñen de
rojo ansiosos por lo que va a decidir
este miércoles la reserva federal y
también en lo que ocurra en ucrania y
los retrocesos en el precio del petróleo
sus principales referencias caen un 7
por ciento a niveles de antes de la
guerra que nos trae como cifra del día
raúl un yate de 140 millones de dólares
como le parece me encantan los yates la
verdad la plata no me alcanza para
comprar ese en 140 millones de dólares
pues mire eso cuesta ya te valen y que
fue incautado en barcelona españa-- de
propiedad de uno de los aliados de
vladimir putin se trata de ser de yemen
shop un ex oficial de la calle que
dirige el conglomerado estatal de la
industria militar rostec a esta
incautación se sumó otra en mallorca la
del yate lady anastasia propiedad de
otro oligarca ruso y en nuestro
imaginario nos vamos hasta parís ahí ya
está lista a natalia con toda la
información de actualidad francesa